mangling multiple classic comic book
teams of outcasts ruining the story of
one of the world's greatest mystical
warriors and how do you make the son of
satan boring of all of these what's the
biggest mistake marvel has ever made
following the success of iron man the
expectations were sky high for the
sequel in the lead-up to the production
one of the biggest changes made to iron
man 2 was terence howard being fired
from the mcu don cheadle replaced him as
james rhodes but that didn't hinder the
anticipation throw in the introduction
of scarlett johansson's natasha romanoff
aka black widow and mickey rourke and
sam rockwell's tag team effort as the
villains of the film all signs pointed
to the sequel outshining the original
unfortunately iron man 2 didn't quite
hit the same lofty standards as its
predecessor as cnn's tom charity said
the whiz-bang stuff here doesn't produce
anything we haven't seen before it mutes
downey's cavalier charisma he's still
what makes this show tick but i'm not
sure we want to see him wrestling with
his own mortality when it's his
instinctive immorality that's his
sexiest attribute
maybe i'll even get laid netflix's
master plan was always to introduce
daredevil jessica jones luke cage and
iron fist in their own series then bring
them together in a big project that
would rival the avengers it was meant to
be the streaming platform's epic team up
just more down to earth than a cgi
extravaganza everything seemed to be on
track as daredevil jessica jones and
luke cage received rave reviews from
critics and fans but then
iron fist arrived
no matter how the defenders was
positioned it couldn't quite escape the
shadow of danny rand's face plant while
the defenders failed to come anywhere
near the same fever pitch of
anticipation that accompanied the
avengers it also wasn't a glum
disappointment instead it was simply
serviceable entertainment deemed
unacceptable due to the high standards
introduced in those first few netflix
shows
last one
comic book movie continuity can be a
slippery slope with so many marvel
projects tying back to other features
series and events then moving forward a
few years back tracking here and there
it feels like there should be a map
handed out with each new release black
widow didn't help the cause while
there's no disputing that natasha
romanov deserved her own movie many fans
were puzzled why her solo film arrived
11 years after the character debuted in
the mcu served as an origin story and
was largely robbed of any dramatic
tension by her death in avengers end
game the film's metacritic score stands
at 67 indicating that it was received
favorably if not spectacularly by
critics for the mcu standards that's
just not good enough all right enough
all of you i didn't say anything
what is it about marvel movies that
almost always makes the second one the
dud you can ponder that as you think
about revisiting age of ultron or wiser
still don't
no one could have foreseen the influence
the original avengers would have on pop
culture and cinema in general it proved
that shared cinematic universes can work
and it heralded a new era for comic book
movies announcing them as the future of
blockbuster entertainment naturally the
sequel had large shoes to film it would
be the second time that earth's
mightiest heroes would be on the big
screen together and everything needed to
be grander and more audacious than
before the action was certainly frenetic
and the film received a host of striking
set pieces but avengers age of ultron
didn't convince everyone that it was in
the same league as its predecessor
reviewers weren't exactly glowing in
their praise for it even if it is
certified fresh at 76 percent on rotten
tomatoes it still is the lowest rated
avengers film to date
hellstrom was meant to kickstart a
darker universe four marvel properties
on hulu which would have also included
ghost rider but it ended up being the
final show for marvel television when it
was shut down and merged with the
overarching marvel studios as a result
hellstrom was essentially dead on
arrival it received little to no hype
and most people tend to forget it even
existed under normal circumstances the
hellstrom siblings aren't exactly a or
even b-list marvel personalities which
certainly didn't help their tv debut
didn't go as planned either since
hellstrom was hammered by professional
reviewers and received a hellish 27
approval on rotten tomatoes the viewing
audience was far more generous to it
though offering a kinder 71 rating
is this some kind of a joke
you're right
looking back the incredible hulk was the
most important movie in the mcu as its
post-credits scene confirmed it took
place in the same universe as robert
downey jr's iron man sadly this huge
reveal and the addition of an a-list
actor like edward norton to the title
role didn't do enough to convince an
audience to actually see the film to
date it remains the lowest grossing film
of the mcu box office slump aside the
incredible hulk didn't capture the
hearts of critics or audiences either as
it holds only 70 fan approval on rotten
tomatoes norton would never again return
as bruce banner with marvel studios
honcho kevin feige telling entertainment
weekly norton's exit was definitely not
one based on monetary factors but
instead rooted in the need for an actor
who embodies the creativity and
collaborative spirit of our other
talented cast members judging by how
this film is hardly mentioned by anyone
at marvel anymore it sounds like a
project they'd all rather forget existed
snow stale beard and defeat with another
subpar second film the mcu somehow seems
to be the opposite of star wars films
when it comes to which is the good one
in the case of thor movies fans fondly
remember the first and third ones but
thor the dark world is hardly ever
mentioned as anything but a punchline
with a 66
critical approval rating on rotten
tomatoes it's the mcu's second worst
ranked film and is often cited as the
worst marvel film it wasn't a bad movie
just a largely forgettable one in fact
does anyone even remember what the plot
was about or who the villain was as
rolling stone said the clutter makes her
head feel like it's about to explode and
not in a good way with wonders upon
wonders instead it seems like arcana
that might show up on the midterm final
the next marvel movie director alan
taylor revealed to collider before the
film's release that part of the reshoot
process was to include more of loki yet
even that didn't manage to save the film
from being one of the mcu's most bland
whoa
costumes a bit much
so tight
for kevin feige eternals was the mcu's
way of paying tribute to the late great
jack kirby unfortunately a number of
critics didn't agree with feige's
thoughts slant magazine's review in
particular pummeled the comparison
saying director chloe zhao ultimately
robs the artist's comic of its sweep by
constantly turning a space opera into a
repetitive character drama on rotten
tomatoes eternals holds a 47
critical approval rating making it the
worst ranked mcu film on the platform
that said there was a disparity in
consensus between the critics and the
viewers as the audience approval sits at
a respectable 78
while it isn't uncommon to see this
happen it proved that eternals might
very well be the mcu's most polarizing
film to date he's wasting our time
after the avengers gobbled up the box
office receipts and went back for
seconds it widened eyes in the
entertainment industry if one property
could be so successful and
practically print money why not tap into
the goodwill and reap similar benefits
across other mediums agents of shield
proved to be the template of the best
way to make an avengers show without the
actual avengers and abc knew it but the
network wanted more and one idea was to
create a series called marvel's most
wanted which would have followed adrian
paliki's bobby morse and nick blood's
lance hunter in 2016 agents of shield
showrunner jeff bell confirmed to ign
that a pilot had been shot and he was
happy with the result of the episode
stating that the two co-stars had
fantastic chemistry however abc wasn't
convinced in a 2016 panel abc
entertainment president channing dungey
said most wanted ultimately at the end
of the day did not feel as strong as
some of the other pilots that we shot
whether that's true or not fans may
never get to find out abc holds the
right to the pilot and there's no
incentive to ever release it
the word you're looking for is never
no not never you're exaggerating
in the comics iron fist is one of the
greatest fighters in the marvel universe
so when the iron fist tv series dropped
on netflix with hardly any magical
elements and elite actor who had no
fighting background it was clear that
the series wasn't about to win over any
longtime fans or fan sitters every bit
is concerning was the missed opportunity
of correcting wrong when it came to
cultural appropriation issues tied to
the character who was created during a
different cultural landscape rather than
expanding the scope of the marvel
universe iron fists daniel rand just
came across as another whiny rich white
guy unsurprisingly season one of iron
fist received a rotten rating of only 20
percent the second season was a marked
improvement receiving 55 approval on
rotten tomatoes but a mortal blow had
already been struck iron fist couldn't
escape the fact that it was the worst of
netflix's marvel series and despite the
continued love for other characters from
these shows no one will be clamoring to
see finn jones's danny rand return in
the mcu any time soon
it's all
kind of crazy
in a review for forbes paul tassie said
inhumans is easily the biggest mistake
marvel has made to date it was a
sentiment shared by many critics at the
time as the series garnered a measly 11
critical approval rating on rotten
tomatoes from its messy cgi to a weak
storyline and even fake looking wigs
nothing was spared from criticism it
came as little surprise when inhumans
only received a single season however
ensign mount who played black bolt
revealed new information at the dallas
fandaze convention in 2019 there's
rumored to be a negotiation going on
with disney plus to reattempt this i
really want there to be another shot at
the inhumans and i wanted to be
successful because i'd love to watch it
i think it is the most interesting
little corner of the marvel universe and
i think it just has to be done it has to
have the right home the right tone and
the right vision overall check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about the marvel
universe are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
you